over the past few decades tech has
transitioned from being a luxury
consumer product to a necessity from
easy access to information and savings
in time energy and effort to mobility
safety and of course entertainment
there's no doubt that tech has become an
integral part of our lives today but
when we're so dependent on a set of
products it becomes very important to
protect the source luckily there's
thousands of tech companies today and
dozens of competitors in each sector so
even if some companies went under we
would have plenty of options to choose
from right
well even though there's thousands of
tech companies there's only a handful of
companies that manufacture all the tech
with the most prominent one being
foxconn
foxconn is a taiwanese contract
manufacturer who assembles 40 of all
global consumer electronics basically
every tech company you can think of
works with foxconn including apple
amazon dell google intel microsoft and
everyone else but despite their
dominance the ethics and morality of the
company are much more questionable so
here's how foxconn became the modern day
plantation that we can't live without
taking a look back the story of foxconn
circles back to a man named terry goh
who was born in taipei county on october
18th 1950. his parents were originally
from mainland china but they had fled to
taiwan near the end of the chinese civil
war in taiwan terry's father continued
his career as a police officer while
terry worked his way through school with
entrepreneurs we often see polar ends of
the spectrum when it comes to education
either they dropped out of school to
start a business or they got a phd from
mit but terry was a middle-of-the-road
student he would end up attending taipei
university of marine technology where he
got his bachelor's it's not clear what
terry majored in but it doesn't seem to
be too influential to his career as
terry ended up getting a low-level job
at a rubber factory following college
for most of his early twenties terry
found himself working many such jobs but
despite his low wages terry was slowly
able to build up some capital thanks to
his frugality by the time he was 24
terry had saved up 7 500 which he would
use to start han hay
he started the company in 1974 with 7
500 in his pocket and a belief that
electronic products would be an integral
part of everyday life gary manufactured
plastic tv parts which had quite a bit
of demand but it was not glamorous by
any means han hae was originally run out
of a rented shed in tuchang and the
staff consisted of 10 elderly workers
who probably weren't able to find jobs
anywhere else due to their age despite
the rough start the tv parts were enough
to make ends meet until terry received
his first breakthrough order
in 1980 atari would ask han hey to
manufacture the control joystick and
this would motivate terry to travel to
the us and try to acquire more western
buyers terry commonly arrived at company
headquarters uninvited and as you would
guess he had security called on him many
times terry wasn't fazed by these
experiences though and he would continue
to hustle his way into hqs and secure a
couple of contracts by the time he
returned to taiwan this new western
contract substantially helped haunt his
financials but this new link with
american companies was just the
beginning
in 1988 terry would purchase the
company's first formal factory in
shenzhen china since then terry has
purchased and built dozens of factories
around the world but this original
factory is still one of the largest
anyway in 1996 terry would get a
contract from compact to manufacture
desktop chassis this quickly grew into
contracts with hp and ibm as well but
the nail in the coffin didn't come till
2000 when foxconn inked a deal with
apple foxconn had already manufactured
parts for apple in the past but this
time they were contracted to produce the
imac itself
this project not only changed foxconn's
balance sheet but it permanently changed
the quality of their manufacturing as we
all know apple has high quality
standards and meeting these standards
was a prerequisite to continue working
with apple
meeting apple's quality standards wasn't
easy though because it wasn't just a
case of sourcing high quality materials
and ensuring excellent consistency in
many cases foxconn had to invent new
manufacturing procedures to make apple
slick design aesthetic a reality while
this was often quite challenging this
helped foxconn make a name for
themselves in a manufacturing space they
were no longer just another asian
manufacturer that competed based on
price
they were turning into the go-to
manufacturer if you wanted
customizability and quality and this new
role would really be put to the test
with the launch of the iphone between
2009 and 2012 apple went from accounting
for 25 percent of foxconn's revenue to a
peak of 55
also apple was actually regularly
changing the iphone's design during this
time period so keeping up with exploding
demand and constantly evolving design
was extremely challenging but by the
time foxconn got to the other side of
the mobile adoption curve they were one
of the most desirable manufacturers in
the world foxconn was receiving orders
from every tech company you can think of
and foxconn's revenue exploded from 40
billion in 2009 to 140 billion dollars
by 2016. in the meantime terry was using
all these newfound profits to acquire
companies left and right but behind the
scenes the story of foxconn was
completely different
one of the biggest reasons that most
people have never heard about foxconn is
not because they're underrated but
because they actively try to fly under
the radar you see the working conditions
at foxconn aren't particularly pleasant
and the less media attention they can
get the better
first of all most factory workers live
at the factories on the bright side this
means that employees don't have to spend
money on housing food recreation and
other basic amenities as all of these
are taken care of by foxconn foxconn has
gotten a bit more stingy over the years
forcing employees to pay for things such
as laundry but for the most part if
you're a foxconn employee your cost of
living is extremely low
the problem though is that unless you're
sleeping eating or performing other
basic day-to-day functions you're
working this means 12 hour shifts 6 days
a week if not 7 days a week also
employees aren't allowed to talk to each
other and they get a 10 minute bathroom
break every 2 hours apple actually
received a lot of backlash for these
working conditions in the early 2010s
and they worked with foxconn to reduce
these hours to 60 hours per week but
really this doesn't mean much
sure foxconn employees are only required
to work 60 hours a week but given that
most of them are in terrible financial
situations they're desperate to work all
the overtime they can which leads to
12-hour shifts once again at least
they're getting paid for the overtime
but again this doesn't really mean much
either as of november 2021 the average
foxconn employee was receiving a base
monthly salary of a whopping 314 dollars
before deductions even if we assume that
this only includes 40 hours of work per
week we're looking at just 1.96 cents
per hour if we assume a more realistic
60 hours per week we're looking at 1.30
cents per hour after mandatory
deductions taxes and pension payments
this drops to a net take-home income of
a measly 98 cents per hour but terrible
working conditions and pay are just
scratching the surface
despite basically operating a tech
plantation foxconn is not breaking any
laws they follow all the minimum wage
and worker requirements laid out by
china and taiwan but this doesn't mean
that they're not crossing ethical
boundaries aside from it being immoral
to pay employees two dollars per hour
and letting them work till exhaustion
the most unethical result of foxconn's
work culture is literally death no asian
foxconn factory worker chooses to work
there because they want to usually
people apply to foxconn because they
have no choice and this is their last
means of survival but unfortunately many
would rather just not live at all than
continue working at foxconn starting in
2010 dozens of factory workers started
jumping off the factory buildings and
this issue actually got so common that
foxconn had to install nets on the sides
of their buildings to reduce deaths i
don't think i have to say anything else
about foxconn's work culture foxconn's
work culture is not the only toxic part
of their business either their business
itself is literally toxic both to
workers and the environment it's no
secret that loads of toxic materials and
chemicals are used in the production of
electronics between 2010 and 2014 13
workers under the age of 20 developed
leukemia many have speculated that this
is due to the employees coming into
contact with benzene in the factories
but foxconn has repeatedly denied this
asserting that there is no contact with
benzene even if this is true though
given the non-negligible number of
leukemia cases it seems like foxconn
does play some role in this moving on to
their environmental impact their most
obvious form of pollution is of course
air pollution running their factories
requires a lot of energy which in turn
leads to a lot of air pollution foxconn
has been working on installing solar
panels and transitioning to renewable
energy but this is still in the early
stages switching to renewable energy
wouldn't clean foxconn though as a large
portion of their pollution is water
pollution many of their factories draw
water from nearby lakes and rivers to
use in the manufacturing process and
then they dump their polluted chemical
water back into the same lakes and
rivers ruining local environments and
potentially poisoning nearby residents
so while foxconn may not be breaking any
legal boundaries their stance on ethical
boundaries is a lot more questionable
activists have tried to fight back
against foxconn's ethical issues for
years now but it's been difficult to
make any real progress the supply
shortage however is causing change the
shortage has revealed the brutal reality
of relying so heavily on one company for
the world's consumer tech foxconn's
clients are pushing foxconn to diversify
outside of asia and they're contracting
out more and more work to other
manufacturers while this does not
directly address the ethical concerns
regarding foxconn it does indirectly
solve many of these issues for example
western countries have much stricter
policies when it comes to workers rights
minimum wage and pollution so hopefully
foxconn's business will become cleaner
as they diversify into western countries
but only time will tell
as for terry he's currently 71 years old
and he still serves as the ceo and
chairman of foxconn he currently ranks
in the top 500 richest people in the
world coming in at 6.15 billion dollars
it's a bit ironic that he's only worth 6
billion dollars given that his company
is the lifeblood of many trillion dollar
companies
but then again he only pays his
employees two dollars per hour so maybe
he doesn't even deserve this in the
first place do you guys think terry
deserves his wealth comment that down
below
also drop a like if you think fox on
employees should be paid way better and
of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one